and finally new rules someone must
design a stylish tick collar for humans
because Lyme disease is becoming
alarmingly common and this is one
disease you do not want to get symptoms
range from fatigue to confusion to
learning problems what doctors call the
full Johnny Depp and a new CDC study
tells us that this summer is gonna be
great for ticks which are still mostly
mysterious to Americans so let me
explain ticks in terms my politically
savvy audience can appreciate like Rudy
Giuliani they latch on suck blood and
sicken everyone around
like Trump they're very hard to remove
like Chris Christie they gorge
themselves and do they nearly explode
and like Stephen Miller they just make
you squeeze their head until it pops
kidding civility and tics are not
actually insects there are tiny
arachnids more closely related to
spiders or Jeff Sessions and they're
very very tough simply removing one
requires a magnifying glass and tweezers
like when stormy gives Trump a [ __ ]
and I hate to say it's not just ticks
anymore mosquitoes are in more places
and can carry the Zika virus yellow
fever West Nile malaria you know 30
years ago this wasn't a problem because
we had this powerful pesticide called
winter yeah global warming isn't just
about souped-up hurricanes and year long
fire seasons and inundated cities rising
temperatures have caused the
creepy-crawly population to breed out of
control because their season is longer
and their range now is further we used
to live in the tropics is now coming
north
forget the border wall we need a border
net these are the migrants we should be
worried about
all of this made me think about a piece
I read a few months ago in the failing
New York Times which made a point I
thought deserved amplification author
pegan Kennedy said when it comes to
staying healthy it's the decisions we
make as a collective that matter more
than any choice we make on our own
in other words matter how much you do
for yourself how right you eat if the
air is full of lead and the bug
populations are out of control and your
city is under water it doesn't matter
you can eat kale till it comes out your
ears
you can stay hydrated slide the run
sunscreen steam your vagina eat your
placenta
work at a standing desk and put a
healing crystal up your ass but there is
no escaping the environment we all live
in in Los Angeles hardly anyone smokes
anymore but we are all still breathing
this you hear it all the time in this
town
I eat paleo I eat organic I do a juice
cleanse ten days and nothing but cayenne
and papaya okay but aren't we expecting
a little too much from the papaya what
papayas like isn't it enough I'm
delicious now I gotta clean your colon
too in the 1970s when America passed a
law to get the lead out of gasoline the
lead levels in our blood
dropped by more than 80% in the 80s when
fluorocarbons were destroying the ozone
layer we banned them and the hole closed
up but that was back when Scientific
American was the name of a magazine now
it's a contradiction in terms
this battle will not be won in the
checkout line at Whole Foods to address
a problem of this scale we need
governments preferably ones that don't
employ Scott Pruett
The Times article pointed out that the
grave is littered with health food
pioneers who didn't even live to the
average lifespan Euell Gibbons swore
he'd lived forever thanks to a diet of
wild plants and now he is a diet for
wild plants dead at 64 Adelle Davis was
so ahead of her time and saying we
should avoid starchy foods like white
bread ironically is toast dead at 7:00
Nathan Pritikin of the Pritikin diet
dead at 69 Clive McKay thought the path
to living past 100 was severe caloric
restriction dead at 69 last words I'm
[ __ ] starving
[Applause]
Michelle Moulton yak sold 70 million
copies of eat yourself slim and died at
66 just before finishing his next book
drink yourself erect Jim Fixx wrote the
complete book of running which his heart
stopped doing at 52 dead while running
meanwhile David Crosby is fine
I don't know the secret to a long
healthy life although I sure hope Ruth
Bader Ginsburg does
[Applause]